vous essaierez les manuels macron estime
que wagner sert les intérêts de moscou
sert les intérêts de la junte est alors
les opérations contre les djihadistes on
en est où et bien c'est aussi ça la
nouvelle guerre c'est la guerre
informationnelle et de l'aveu même de
l'état major français les russes sont
bien plus avancés que les occidentaux
sur ce point on le voit d'ailleurs sur
un autre dossier en ukraine la guerre
informationnelle c'est par exemple de
faire de réfuter ou de confirmer enfin
en tout cas de laisser un clair obscur
sur la présence de ses sulfureux
paramilitaires qui n'ont pas opéré que
en centrafrique en ukraine ou en au
mozambique mais un peu partout c'est
d'hydre qui est en fait le bras armé de
la diplomatie de vladimir poutine c'est
très habile en ce qui concerne le mali
puisque des paramilitaires de wagner il
n'y a que les occidentaux les américains
le colonel porte parole les chefs des
armées on lui a demandé des preuves
tangibles on en a pas nécessairement
mais finalement ça suffit pour vladimir
poutine pour faire avancer ses pions
puisque le symbole même de la présence
de ces paramilitaires mais un énorme
marasme diplomatique mais ce qui me
concerne ce sujet les trois fois au mali
en deux mois pour enquêter sur la
présence de ces paramilitaires de wagner
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il y en a
évidemment n'en est pas dans le même
paradigme centrafricain avec une énorme
présence de milliers d'hommes il s'agit
certainement d'un cadran est tout
simplement mais ça fait le reste et ça
permet notamment à ses éléments de
langage des des maliens et des
souverainistes malien de dire que les
russes sont maintenant avec les les
forces maliennes sur le terrain là où
les français vont partir et eux font du
chiffre mais tout cela c'est encore des
éléments de langage c'est cette fameuse
guerre informationnelle merci beaucoup
syrie